vitara gladinet is a musician in regular
life but he's just received his cool up
notice for the ukrainian army so he's
trying on uniforms yeah will do Tom
chorus knee I think I can still be
useful there when the time comes I'll do
my duty as God wills it doc stanitsa
budet acabo de warrior but I don't want
to become cannon fodder never do harm at
Nene awesome Valeri also helps supply
soldiers fighting in the East with
jackets and trousers the funds come from
private donations such supplies are
crucial now the last two weeks have seen
a surge in combat operations Valeri is
sure the Ukrainian army will win the
bites are like now in the bathroom taco
supreme will win this fight not
necessarily Chesney attracting the enemy
has incurred heavy losses but they keep
getting new weapons from Russia the resi
technica the both civilized Between the
separatists strongholds of Donetsk and
Luhansk the town are still in government
hands but its location at the crossroads
of major highways and rail lines makes
it a key strategic target for the
separatists with the time so as Muslims
we're trying to isolate debat so as
quickly as possible when you think you
do so but we do not want too many of our
soldiers to die with them also the
operation will take a little longer than
I would like athelas verse chorus the
townspeople have had to fund largely for
themselves with little help coming in
from outside it's difficult for the Red
Cross to even get close to contested
areas
it sent up an emergency shelter 10
kilometers from the front many of the
people here had lost everything a lot of
what are you I had a job but now
everything has been destroyed so we
moved here or more precisely we've been
displaced by the separatists they
shelled us very heavily but also sealing
a bond villain will mrs. yellow up your
pilot there's no electricity at the
shelter and it's freezing cold food and
other supplies have become scarce and
the samondel yeah it's been very hard on
the front lines the winter conditions
mean many people can't leave so they
stay here which makes it very difficult
to buy food and eat on a daily basis
noosaville assertion in Europe balearic
lagunes carries on nonetheless the
United Nations now says that more than
5,000 people have died in the Ukrainian
conflict and the situation appears to be
escalating